there was a host on msnbc tiffany cross
who just recently attacked bill maher
bill maher is a
liberal but he's a white guy and he's a
liberal
who is not totally politically correct
and so he
sometimes goes after the excesses of the
woke people and you know he
reserves most of his criticism for the
right but a little bit for the left
that was too much for msnbc
delves right into the identity politics
of identity politics
this is a black woman saying that that
white man
needs to shut his mouth okay bill maher
has been whack for a long time from his
make out session with the blackface
expert
megan kelly to his infamous use of the
n-word on his show for which he later
apologized
and his continual mostly white weekly
panels where he sings
sob songs to them about the perils of
the shrinking demographic
and chides anyone who falls even
slightly outside of his myopic
privileged view anybody find it
interesting that this
quote-unquote liberal ally is sounding a
lot like a moderate fox news contributor
bill maher you do not get to tell people
of color
what they should or should not be
offended by
stay in your lane slim try that instead
of standing on your alabaster perch
every week to crap on other people's
lived experience
while providing a safe haven for
well-established white supremacists
because i gotta tell you this old angry
white man act is so played
the truth is what's happening now is an
evolution
and you are fighting for your power and
privilege to not become fossilized
while basking in the rays of your own
non-existent cleverness and comedy bit
circa three decades ago
and quite frankly it's just offensive at
this point
the country like it or not is changing
in real time
and sadly fake time with bill maher is
not
whoa man this woman is a vile
vile racist right do you i mean i know
the word racist doesn't mean anything
anymore because the left has watered it
down to mean nothing
but if racist means anything it means
that woman
right this entire attack is on bill
maher because he's white
his alabaster perch stay in your lane
white man
how dare you question the lived
experiences of black people how dare you
question the lived experience of that
white guy named bill maher
by your own logic you're saying one
cannot
ever criticize the opinions and actions
of someone of another race right but
that's exactly what you're doing and
you're doing it
on the basis of race even crazier
you'll very often hear the left
say that there is this crazy conspiracy
theory
that the left wants to
replace white people as a demographic in
the united states and that they're
cheering it on as the process of
immigration and and things like that
lead to a declining demographic that's a
sick white supremacist conspiracy theory
she's she's the one articulating it
she's the one saying the demographics
are changing it's inevitable you're
losing your power
and that's good this is evolution you're
you're ossifying
you're turning into a fossil on the
basis of your race
and other races are gaining in power and
we're gonna have a racial politics
and you just need to shut up and take it
that i don't know of any well first of
all how many white supremacists are
there in america i don't know like three
and they all work for the fbi but
but i've never heard of a white
supremacist
articulating that alleged conspiracy
theory nearly as clearly as
that woman on msnbc vile
vile politics that's what she's saying
to him
this is it i i don't think that she
knows what she's saying i don't i think
she
much like the the broad the left
broadly and this leftist broad by the
way
i i think that she is living in
the unknown known that this just this
ideology is
blinding her to the the glaring
contradictions in what she's saying or
if it's not a contradiction or if it's
not hypocrisy then it's just this double
standard
and it's double standard along the lines
of race and
to a lesser degree sex in this case
because bill maher's big transgression
is not just that he's white but he's a
white
man and that's very terrible and you're
not not allowed to criticize anybody
i'm glad you liked that clip we've got a
whole episode it's called unknown knowns
check it out right here on youtube you
can get it also on apple podcast spotify
all those different places
you can also buy my book the national
bestseller
speechless controlling words controlling
minds thank you so much to everyone who
has ordered that book already really
appreciate
all of you if you haven't gotten it yet
go get it see you next time
you